valerent newest du list is almost here
and he brings something to the game that
we've never seen before but is that
actually a good thing iso's kid is
pretty crazy but we know how this goes
either his abilities are so strong that
he breaks the game or he doesn't make
enough of an impact to matter so is ISO
good or is he another shitty agent like
[Applause]
deadlock all right so before I get into
all things ISO I just want to remind you
to like the video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications it
really helps us out and also prevents
you from missing the next episode of
cracked last week Riot gave us our first
look at ISO a new duelist coming to
valerant with the start of episode 7 act
3 and his kit is very interesting ISO C
ability is an indestructible wall that
blocks bullets it travels similarly to a
harbor Cascade but you can't stop it his
Q sends out a projectile that applies a
debuff on hit that doubles damage from
all sources it can also pass through
walls like an omen paranoia ISO
signature ability is double tap press it
once to start a focus timer once that
timer is complete any enemies you damage
or kill will have this orb pop up over
their head shooting that orb gives you a
shield that absorbs one instance of
damage from any source that could be a
Raaz alt or a single shot from a classic
just any piece of damage despite the
fact that double tap looks like a mini
aim Labs routine the most unique part of
his kit is actually his alt this thing
looks crazy it pulls you and the first
enemy at hits into an arena where you
both fight to the death using only your
guns a lot of people are comparing his
alt to the goag and War Zone a Mor
Kaiser alt in League or even Gojo's
domain expansion but I got to be honest
it feels weird as hell for valerin
forcing a 1v1 duel isn't something we've
seen from a valerin all before and it
doesn't seem like there's any sort of
interaction that prevents it either it
just isolates you and your opponent and
the better aimer wins and as expected
everyone lost their when they saw
it gone oh
let's
go the iso certainly looks unique but we
said the same thing about deadlock and
well look at how she turned out
sometimes valerent most creative agents
just don't pan out at a competitive
level the best characters in the game
tend to play it safe with kits built
around utility Mobility or map control
but luckily I was invited to test out
ISO ahead of his release along with some
pros and other content creators so at
the start of most rounds I popped double
tap before taking an engagement but
often found myself forgetting to shoot
the orb immediately after I got the kill
after a few rounds I finally started to
remember and began chaining kills
together and it was honestly really
satisfying trying to isolate fights and
rep peaking with the shield activated
the wall was good for taking space but
if you don't follow it closely and send
it out on specific angles then you'll
die like this although I really should
have pre-fired ethos in that corner I
didn't find much value with his q but me
MIM and I condition the opponents to
stay away from B main for most of the
defensive Side by comboing it with a
shock dart at the start of most rounds
similar to a fade Seas or other utility
that applies vulnerability you typically
get the most value by comboing it with
other damage dealing utility as for
iso's alt my plan was to use it any time
that I knew my opponents were on an Eco
or halfby there were a few times that I
actually lost to an opponent with a
weaker buy and this felt as awful as
you'd expect but for the most part it
worked out making the a really effective
way to take an opponent out of a round
where you already have an advantage it's
also cool that if you pop double tap
before you use the alt and you win that
1 V one you can bring a shield back with
you and you can also bring the shield
with you into the alt that said it's not
an alt that will suddenly turn the tides
in a round that you're losing or
struggling in which is tough given what
some of iso's competition in the Duelist
role can do overall I had a lot of fun
playing as ISO he's a cool agent with a
lot of clip potential thanks to his
resets and I'm I'm sure we'll be seeing
a lot of him in matchmaking he's kind of
another selfish duelist like Raina on
the other hand the only thing that
really bothered me when playing against
ISO was getting used to the shield there
were a few times where I assumed I had
done enough to kill the enemy but lost
the gunfight because I wasn't used to
the extra time to kill so far we've just
been talking about ranked but will the
pros actually use ISO well we've already
seen coaches like Anders and Kaplan
debating his value and many people just
don't think he's good enough to replace
the meta duelist in Pro play and FNS
actually brought up an interesting point
after chamber came in and basically
ruined the game it almost seems like
Riot is intentionally releasing
underpowered agents the last like two
characters are underpowered as but in
matches you're never going to see this
character being played there are and the
way you have to look at it is what does
he do that others don't do and what do
others do that he doesn't have and in
comparison he's way worse than most
agents especially in his class he's
basically worse than every other dualist
and I have to agree with FNS here ISO
was a lot of fun to play but he still
feels like a crappier Raina and with no
movement abilities it's hard to imagine
pro teams picking him over jet or Rays
now Riot has tried to justify that
design decision we wanted to avoid
certain things like like mobility and
things like that um mostly because yeah
we have characters that do do that and
like while those are very premium
outputs for a dualist I think I wanted
to try to explore ways of like how do we
get you to take space or be confident in
in different ways right um and so that's
kind of where the shield was born um
it's like you know if you can take an op
shot I think that's a hell of a lot of
confidence for a lot of people and as it
played out it's that was true he's not
supposed to be like really fast and like
breaking SES like that but he's supposed
to like power through and you know can
tank in those ways if he's playing well
problem is that the best du lists in the
game right now do hit hard and fast and
win those first engagements before
dipping out into safety and ISO just
doesn't fit within the current meta
which makes me and a lot of other people
worry that he might just just be kind of
mid ISO officially releases next week
and although the community might
eventually find a place for him within
the meta right now he feels
underwhelming that being said he is a
lot of fun to play and he's a hell of a
lot better than deadlock that's not
saying much but trust me it's
something thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring the notification Bell
for Unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit us up on our
Twitter Instagram Facebook and Tik
Tok